well uh thanks very much for the more
than kind uh introduction
and also for inviting me to this
exceptional occasion which i i do
appreciate
um so uh so i think this new institute
is partly about questions and in fact i
noticed that the first three
talks this morning all start with uh
what why and why
um but i actually have a question mark
at the end so i'm really asking a
question and uh
so i've been asked to write an article
with some such titles so i'm very
motivated to listen to what what you
think about this as well
um
but the i think one of the other things
the institute is about is about people
uh crossing uh
boundaries so people who have a
background in one area
moving into a different area
and
so a lot goes into that because as you
move to different areas totally
different assumptions a totally
different history
so i thought i'd start with uh
very
three
small items of history to do with
computational neuroscience which helped
me to understand things um
so when i first started working on on
the brain
so one sunday i was reading the
newspaper
and there was a report of a
very well-known neurobiologist a nobel
prize winner saying that
the last thing he wants
is for neurobiology to descend to the
depths of physics
whereas the theoreticians who tell the
experimentalists what to do
and so i was a bit disturbed by this and
i was wondering what was going on
so then some years later i went to talk
by peter diane who said i should look at
the writings of of kahal so kahal
was maybe
certainly one of the main founders of of
neuroscience
so he
was a proponent of the neuron doctrine
that neurons are separate cells like the
rest of the body
and of course his very attractive
drawings still fill textbooks and and
the internet
um
but um
also uh he had he had very strong uh
ideas about what research was like
and
he was clearly an experimentalist
and i was urged to look at this book
which he wrote advice for a young
investigator where he tried to say what
was him what was important for research
and what to young people should stay
away from
so there was this is extraordinary
chapter five
which is called diseases of the will so
these are things you better avoid if you
want to be a successful researcher
and it's a rather surprising list so
people who didn't like were
contemplaters bibliophiles in polyglots
megalomaniacs instrument addicts misfits
and last but not least theorists
and
he really doesn't say very nice things
about any of these categories
and i don't want to ruin your day by by
quoting too much from it
but um but okay but i find one quotation
which is almost uh acceptable
and i think that
shows
i think gives you some insight into
where
uh neuroscience is coming from so
so let's emphasize again the this
obvious conclusion a scholar's positive
contribution is measured by the sum of
the original data that it contributes
hypotheses come and go but data remain
theorists desert us so our data defend
us
there are true resources our real estate
and our best pedigree in the eternal
shifting of things only they will save
us from the ravages of time and from the
forgetfulness or injustice of men
to risk everything on the success of one
idea is to forget that every 15 or 20
years theories are replaced or revised
so many apparently conclusive theories
in physics chemistry geology and biology
have collapsed in the last few decades
on the other hand they will establish
facts of anatomy and physiology and of
chemistry and geology and the laws and
equations of astronomy and physics
remain immutable and define
criticism so uh
so i think one learns a lot from that
one almost agrees with that um but the
interesting thing of course is that he
does have these laws and equations of
astronomy and physics at the end which
he which he likes
so i presume he likes theories which are
established but just the
struggle of ideas being debated before
they accept is a bit too painful and he
doesn't want to watch that happening
um okay so um so that's chapter one and
i think this is a
good articulation of the experiment list
viewpoint i think
um so uh chapter two about 40 years on
is computation
so which came from nowhere
so turing's paper famously says
we may compare a man in the process of
computing a real number to machine which
is only capable of a finite number of
conditions
so turing
was
identifying computing with something
which did a human-like phenomena
now i think one of the first papers
after that which quoted turing but was
outside the computer science
logic world
was the famous macaulay and pitts paper
on neural nets
and they said
they devised some sort of neural net and
that's easily shown that every net can
compute only such numbers as kind of
turing machine but each of the latter
numbers can be computed by such a net
this is our interest as affording
psychological justification for the
turing definition of computability
which again is an interesting
way of going but so if we're going to
award
have an award for the earliest
lens on computation
then
maybe it should be touring but if you
disqualify touring then maybe the
mcculloch pittsburgh
early paper which really exploits
computation to say something about
neural computation
so so the idea that computation must be
what goes on in the brain kind of became
so obvious
and by the 1950s you know cognitive
psychologists said well it must be
computation
um but where has that taken us um so um
so then there came this phase of
computational neuroscience
and just the one person i'd like to
discuss a bit is is david marr who is
the one who kind of speaks to me most um
so he died when he was 35 in 1980
but if you go to any talks on
computational neuroscience and what they
should be aiming at
the most frequent quotation is from his
book on computer vision published a
couple of years later
where he said that
this is what you have to do
so basically
there are three levels uh
there's a computational theory where you
discuss what the goal of the computation
is
you know why is it appropriate what's
the logic of the strategy by which it
can be carried out
so the second level is representation
algorithm
you know how can this computational
theory be implemented
input output
what's the transformation
and the third level is is implementation
in hardware
um
so um
so this is
sounds so reasonable you have to ask you
know how could this fail and of course
it sounds so reasonable because it just
seems to be an eloquent description of
computer science this is what we teach
our students that's what you should you
should be doing
and in fact neuroscientists they
don't actually follow this very
carefully they like quoting it
now the reason why it's interesting to
discuss
is that ma
is a very interesting person to discuss
so first
he did follow this program
earlier in writing three very detailed
papers on the cerebellum the cortex and
hippocampus
and
so he was a mathematician by background
knew all about
neurobiology
and the cerebellum paper is probably the
theory is still alive it's a plausible
hypothesis still to have
so he really worked at this
but
the ironic fact is that he gave up on
this
and already in 1973 he
he kind of
changed fields
he wrote i do not expect to write many
more papers in theoretical
neurophysiology at least not for a long
time
and interesting question is why
and in a later book review
okay i should add but i should be very
surprised if my
69 and 71 papers turned out to be very
wrong
so
so the cortex paper here omitted but he
thought maybe the other ones were on the
right track so it wasn't that he thought
that was his work was worthless
but he gave up and then in a book review
he gave kind of the two reasons which
people give for why you shouldn't pursue
this field at all
so one is that we don't know enough
with problems of biological information
processing there's been almost no
experience and once an intuition is the
best unworthy
and trustworthy
and then the other reason is the even
worse one is that maybe there's no
theory
so it may even be that biological
information processing admits of no
general theories except one so
unspecific
has to have only descriptor and no
predictive powers
so maybe uh if you look at a simple
animal it's got a circuit there's
nothing to say about it besides
it is what it is
um
so so the question is what should we
do now
and
so in particular with more knowledge in
computer science how should we you know
update this was this wrong or
why does this not give us a a good
direction
and
so
the direction i went in is the very
simple one motivated by the idea that if
you uh
show me a briefcase
and say that
it's got an orange and three unread
papers in it
and give me a theory of it then
throw up my hands i don't know but if
you say i've got a briefcase and a
million dollar dollars in banknotes in
there
give me a theory that would be more
interesting so you know how do you get
those banknotes in there what kind of
banknotes could they be no why are you
carrying around that money
so once there's some significant uh
constraints then one can have a theory
so so the approach which
which i've been pursuing is
certainly accept
mars statements which are kind of
self-explanatory i think
but one thing we've learned in computer
science is that
we need the models of models of
computation
so for example say just saying
algorithms and hardware representation
implementation is not enough
we know there are many levels of
explanation we have to decide on a level
and explain what's appropriate at that
level so that's what we do in computer
science
and
the other equally important thing is
that we want to
solve problems which are which are hard
which which is hard for the brain to do
if it's too easy
then there may be many ways of doing it
and
there may be no theory of a theory of it
but if we can't
even imagine how the brain does it
then uh we've got a much better chance
of
of guessing how he does it and of
exploiting our knowledge of of
constraints
okay
so of course his emphasis on constraints
is also based on the success which
computer science has had in
in analyzing
various phenomena
so some of computer science looks at
communication
the cost of communication under various
conditions
and a bit more difficult is if you
actually want to compute on this on this
on this n bits of information
and so we started computational
complexity it's a very successful field
and if you want to go higher then
besides computing a function you can
also ask questions about how you can
learn the function if no one gives the
program for it but you have to learn it
from from examples
and one thing with some of us have been
involved in more recently is one level
up still
which is evolution so it's a kind of
learning where
the extra darwinian constraints so again
our bodies have compute functions
and
how did they get there
so
so i like this picture i think it shows
us that in computer science we're
studying phenomena which are very
relevant to biology
and people should uh uh know about this
and we should be able to help biologists
and uh in that uh um with that idea i've
actually taken some time to write a book
hopefully of general interest to try to
persuade people outside computer science
that what we have to say is of
is of some interest
so basically explaining the fact that in
computer science we study these things
like computation communication learning
and evolution
so now
what i'm going to talk talk about uh
oops today is uh
lost my device slides my mind um is
um
um
is is is the brain and for that we don't
need all of this
and so in particular
um i think my slides got reversed
somehow
so for for some of for the most
difficult okay so after
some uh effort i was a bit surprised to
find out that in the brain
the main impediments come very very far
down
so it seems to me that the brain is very
communication uh bounded
and you can get many constrained
problems just from that
but we can't ignore the rest so for
example for for evolution
i think one important thing which
i want to keep to is the idea that if
you have some theory of cortex
then
even a random jumble of neurons should
do something interesting so it's very
hard to evolve if your theory needs a
very special structure for neurons then
um
you should need it and as far as
inductive learning which is what i hope
to apply to understand the brain again
one can take a simplistic view that back
in the 50s
frank rosenblatt had the idea of a
perceptron
and
the perceptron is a powerful learning
method
it's state-of-the-art with suitable
mutations
um and also we know that things which
are if you want to learn much more their
impediments
and on the other side we know that in
fact neuron like things can execute it
so it's a very fortuitous uh
thing this perceptron and if we keep the
very simple learning methods then
already we have some solve some problems
okay so um
okay so what so what does one do
um so um so i'll try to follow this uh
path which i described
um
mob with a slide updating
so we need a model of computation so
i'll describe that
and given a model of computation what
computer scientists do is
dance around this triple
so we have to specify what tasks we're
trying to compute
and then we need an algorithm and we
need to represent the data
and somehow these three things have to
be pursued simultaneously
um you can't just study an algorithm if
you don't know what it's for and how you
represent data
so this is kind of what computer science
does
and what i think one can try to apply to
to neuroscience
um okay so um
okay so of these already ma said that
the
primary unresolved issue is what
functions you want implemented and why
so if you want to say what's the hardest
part of neuroscience it's it's guessing
what the brain is trying to do so you
have to try to guess what function is
computing
once you've done that then maybe the
rest will do we can work them in like
way figure out
but this one is the um
a hard one
okay so um
so as i said uh so my starting
observation is that the brain is
communication challenged
so obviously through evolution
neurons evolved somehow and our brains
got huge and
as we parallel computers somehow they
um outgrew their comp their
communication abilities
and so obviously each neuron is
connected to a very small fraction of
the others
and also the influence of each neuron on
a on even the ones it's connected to
is often is often rather small
so if uh
if there are many people and
you can only influence other people very
weakly
you know if for example to decide
anything like what you're going to have
for for lunch it needs a committee of 20
people to decide then it's kind of a
different regime
and the question is is the brain like
that
so
okay um
okay so um so what um
i do so in recognition of this
is um
is to try to formulate a question
which is uh
which is challenging for this model of
computation which which is weak in in
communication abilities
and so i call these random access tasks
so if the brain is hard at communicating
and you want to find a thing which is it
finds difficult to compute
then do one which really challenges its
communication abilities
and the abilities which ask it to
randomly communicate
seem to be the most severe
so
so i'll give you a list of of tasks
which i think the brain ought to be able
to able to compute and which i'll try to
explain how it might compute
and uh there'll be two types of
operations so one operation is that you
actually allocate some neurons to a new
to a new concept
and then there'll be some other
operations where you where you build up
knowledge about them
okay so it seems um
these are two complement two
complementary sets of uh operations
and uh
so to illustrate this a new concept so
suppose you consider the time when you
first heard
the name tiger woods
so so i claim that you you this is a new
concept
um and you allocate the storage to it
somehow
and one way would be is you somehow
allocate it uh from the from the name
um so um
okay so what i call this operation is
hierarchical memorization
where um for um
for two stored items which may be tiger
and woods
which you already know
the task is to allocate uh
some new neurons
for this new concept which will tiger
woods
and you you will change your your
weights in your brain to set up a
circuit so in the future when you hear a
and b tiger woods you'll be reminded of
this of this new concept
um so this is a kind of a
this kind of operation is like setting
up a circuit in your brain it's a bit
different from traditional
um
theoretical neuroscience solutions where
we tend to follow computers so the
traditional view
is that
memory is like storing a string and
getting a string out
so i'm more trying to construct circuits
which do something
because kind of if you just store
strings it's not quite clear what you do
with the strings
okay
um so um
and there's a various other implied
things here so i do mean that you you
acquire new concept and
with this new concept of tiger woods
i want to be able to do
every other operation later on
which i could do with
with the ones i previously had
just like building a finding a signing
story to a new concept which is an equal
citizen with what you had already
okay so so this is uh will be my first
operation
and uh
so
so in neuroscience people don't look at
this but in in psychology people have
studied this kind of thing they call it
chunking so chunking is when you
make a concept
a compound concept from some simpler
ones and this compound concept is it's
as natural to you as the simpler ones so
for example
chess experts can recognize the complex
which the novice won't and for them this
is a simple simple chunk
okay so we take this seriously
okay so so then we'll have some other
operations um which um
which will be relations among the
represented concepts so once you've got
concepts represented you want to do all
kinds of other interesting things
and
basic one is what i call association
so if you hear if you know who david
beckham is and you already know what the
state of retirement is and you hear the
news that david beckham has retired
then you don't have to assign your
storage you just have to establish some
sort of link
and the semantics of this will be that
you for two stored items a and b
david beckham and retired you want to
change your circuits so that in the
future
when uh
um when david beckham is uh you reminder
of david beckham then
you will also be said oh yes he is
retired
okay
so if you don't know what who david
beckham is you have to do the operation
of the previous slide
okay um
so this is one uh
operation which i'd like to do
and there
are some others
um
so some other operations are inductive
learning so besides just
an association i want to learn more
complicated things
um so the last one super memorization is
like a definition
um i want someone says that you know
it gives me some information which i
have to remember inductive learning is
is inductive learning where from many
examples you generalize
and um and so there i'm happy to
instantiate some simple known algorithm
like the perceptron algorithm
and the
hard part isn't the algorithm the hard
part is that
the
the verb the target variable and the
dependent variables are somewhere
sitting in your brain
and you know so normally with inductive
learning
the setup is that there's this box and i
want this box to recognize elephants
but in your brain your elephant will be
some neuron somewhere and the dependent
variables will be somewhere else and you
have to set up a circuit which does this
thing
okay
so we want to be able to do all these
things
okay and the general strategy is that
where there are no theories
where there are no viable theories what
do we do so i just want to back up a bit
so where we're going here is that
i will introduce this
model of computation and the intention
is that it underestimates the brain so i
don't want people to complain that i'm
i'm trying to do too much
and i then specify some some set of
tasks which
which i think are interesting and
unavoidable
then i show that these tasks can be
executed on the model
and
finally i want to show that i really
want to
test this i want to give a very heavy
load to this to this system
so the interesting things about these
tasks i've given you is that we can
remember
we can execute sequences of thousands of
them we can memorize something we can
learn something that we can memorize
something else we can learn a new
concept
and after you've done this for half a
lifetime
you haven't disturbed too much what you
learned at the beginning
okay so so we will do some of that
okay so there is a model which i don't
want to
give the details of too much
so the model the main idea of the model
is that it shouldn't be too uh creative
it has to be something pretty mundane so
no one says it's it's not realizable
but the main thing is it's got
parameters i want to cost everything i
want to show that things are realizable
even
in the presence of strict constraints
and the three numbers i'll need for the
uh resource constraints are the number
of neurons n
how many connections each one has which
is d
and then the strength of the of the
interaction of the synaptic weights
so if there's a certain threshold um so
you need so many uh so much activity
to cause a neuron to fire and to
communicate
the question is how many neurons have to
how many presynaptic neurons have to be
active for that to happen
so if k is is one
then that means that
a single neuron can cause a neighbor to
to fire but if k is large like a
thousand then you you need a thousand
neurons to cause a neighbor to fire and
this question is very important and it's
kind of unresolved uh
what's really operating in the brain
okay so we have three uh three
parameters
um and this will be a model of
computation so it needs more
so we will have we will have five number
of state we have states in in in the
neuron bodies and we have synaptic
strengths um
like the mcculloch pitts model
and then we'll allow local updates and
the updates will be all local and
natural and nothing
you would complain about
and
and of course a critical
uh problem in neural computation is
timing everything is going on in
parallel so this model of computation
has to say something about timing
and there it takes a simple approach
so the algorithms are local
so each on each neuron writes a little
local algorithm so it sees it's
inputting signals and it does something
that's all it's got state
and it detects
which of his neighbors are firing
and then it does something okay
um so it's got some very loose timing
notion of timing um
which is that um
each neuron can kind of count one two
three and when it got to three it's
pretty sure the other neurons have also
counted to about one two three it
doesn't require a very sophisticated
timing mechanism
but the idea is that if you uh
in a cast your gaze at a new place
you've got a simultaneous input
and this prompts this gives us gives a
simultaneous prompt to your neurons to
to be active
and
so
your neurons do something
and start counting one two three and
they know which stage of this process
that they're at so if they get an input
at the second time slots from their
neighbor they know it's the second time
slot
so it's a minimal notion of timing you
need some notion of timing and it's got
a minimal notion so one can make up a
very traditional kind of model of neural
computation which
is pretty
innocuous
okay so
so how do we represent
information
so already uh
in how i described my tasks i kind of
gave that away
so um you know in compute computation
you have to be specific you have to
commit yourself so when you represent
tiger woods
then i say yes you do devote a certain
number of neurons to
two tiger woods and in fact a number are
okay
and
and the question of whether um
you can experimentally figure out where
your tiger what neurons are
depends very very largely on on how big
this r is
so if you've only got 10 neurons to
represent tiger woods then it's very
hard to find them and no one will have
found them but if you've got millions
then
you know
if you try various electrodes
then people will
and in fact it's found that in some
parts of the brain it's easy enough to
distinguish to
detect what real world correlates the
firing of neurons corresponds to
and in other parts of the brain it isn't
um
and
and then once one
once was said that then there's one more
decision to make which is whether um so
do you allow okay given that you devote
78 euros to tiger woods
are these 78 neurons
diverted entirely to tiger woods or are
some of the neurons also shared by other
concepts
and here there's the obvious trade-off
that
if each neuron you want to represent
just one concept then
the computation is easier
but
then if you represented if you devoted
too many neurons to one concept you
can't represent too many concepts
so there are reasons to look at both
disjoint representations and shared
representations
okay
okay um
okay so okay um
so so what kind of graphs do we look at
um
well um
so i look at around at
random graphs
and uh so part of the uh where this work
is going is that
um
the
your
your
connect the connectivity of your brain
will have to have certain good
properties to be able to do all these
all these tasks
and there's some interesting history
here here as well
so we know that
there's this well-known notion of
expanders in computer science
which is the notion that if you've got a
graph
then
any set of say half the nodes
are connected to
a big fraction a fraction more than half
of the nodes altogether
so it's like you know
if you pick any half questions
do any half of the people in the
audience know between them significantly
more than than their own number
and being expanded is a very good
property random graphs are expanders
and
so in fact uh historically expand is
apparently first were discovered in the
in the context of someone trying to do a
theoretical neuroscience there's a paper
a little known to recently michael
mogrove and boston
who
basically tried to explain why
so in the brain
you can take the view that the
connections fill up the volume and the
cells on the periphery
so the
if you want n nodes then the volume the
connections take up n to the three
halves of space
and so they show that effectively that
any graph which in expander
has this property
okay so
what i'm interested in will be
properties of graphs which are certainly
expanders are essential
but they will be
more more demanding
okay
okay so
so what does one do so basically i've
told you everything that
one needs to know for i've got a model
of computation i've got some tasks
and you just have to work out the
consequences
um so okay so
um
what if you want to you've just heard
the news that david beckham has retired
so what happens according to this theory
how is this association implemented
well i've i've told you everything
so i said that david beckham is
represented by cell neurons a the notion
of retirement is represented by a cell
of neuron c
and that there's some number r which is
the
some replication factor
so you've got neurons altogether in your
brain
we have a parameter which tells you how
dense this random graph is
and
and we also know the influence of
of each neuron on another so in
particular we assume that um you need k
neurons to fire
k pre-synaptic neurosurfin for a neuron
to be woken up
so from these facts you kind of know
everything
and
so if beta is this bernoulli
distribution so it's the probability
that in our coin tosses
if you have probability d or end of
success you get at least k successes
so you want this to be
close to one
which basically means that
from the a set
for every node in the retired set
you want that to be at least k
connections
okay
so for for a to be able to
cause uh
to remind you of retirement
um
there's a graph theoretic requirement
okay so
so the graph theoretic property of of
this is um
is straightforward and of course the the
main point one is making here is that
so this is the simplest uh formulation i
have is that here we have no
intermediate nodes
all the communication is done directly
from the inputs to the outputs
and this works as long as the a is huge
and the and the c is huge
even if there are a few connections from
each neuron
um
you will have uh
you know enough connections to each
retired neuron
to wake it up from from the neurons okay
so this works if
this picture works if you've got a very
r is very large
okay
so
okay
and then the last thing is that this is
just the graph theoretic requirement you
also want that you can
change the weights
to to affect this
so
so to realize this you have some weight
changes
and you have to show that by prompting a
and c in some
in some way
constant protocol you can affect the
weight changes so there's a model of
computation and the weight change is
happening when you execute these little
programs riding on the on the
um
on the neurons okay
okay so quickly the so the other
operation i had is when you create
new new uh neurons for so create a new
representation
so this is different from previous one
but
very similar in other cases so in this
case a and b are already allocated
question is where on earth do you store
this new concept tiger woods so this uh
so this issue of where you store a new
concept
is should be there in every theory
theory of
of how the cortex works so my proposed
solution is that the answer is the
simplest one
so where you store your new concept
are just those neurons which are well
connected
to the neurons you're using to
to key the representation
okay so um
if you happen to store tiger woods uh
from his on his name
then it'll be the nodes which are
somehow well connected to both tiger and
woods
but you could have stored it by
on golf and something else or on his
appearance or anything or anything else
okay and again you get some
graph theoretical constraints
derived from the bernoulli distribution
and again you have to show that
by when you want to do this act of of
memorization
then if you trigger
the sets of neurons in the right uh
conjunction protocol then you change
some ways to do that
okay
okay so um so things aren't quite so
easy because
i've given you the positive requirements
but they also have some negative ones
so okay so when you
fire a and b you want c to fire
but i have to be very clear so far on
the semantics so for example what if you
only fire 90 of a or 70 of a or what
should happen
so certainly
um if only say
50 of the of the tiger euron's fire
maybe a hundred percent of the woods
neurons fire should you be reminded of
tiger woods okay so that's that that's
the issue that's the issue um
and uh
okay so there's negative constraints
which ensure that
um
that unintended by-products don't happen
okay so um
so
one can prove little
theorems that each of these act
separately is
is doable
but the real issue is how what happens
if you want to
really memorize a long sequence of
associations so
in a lifetime we can do these acts every
day
and although we
forget we're what's amazing is that we
don't destroy our previous memories too
much
so with
uh vital development with or mainly
heated some very significant large-scale
simulations
on a large computer
and basically
the task was that you
had a network
and then you gave it a sequence of
associations
yes some base concepts and you give
things of associations uh
uh david beckham retired david beckham
did something else retirement means
something else
there was some inductive learning so
inductive learning means that to a
target you want to learn about the golf
you give many inputs over different
different times
and maybe interspace between other
things
and
you still want it to work
okay um so we did this
and um
then you want to find out at some point
this thing will fail and you want to see
so these things fill up they don't
forget so at one point they will fail
you want to know
what's the limit
um
and uh so so now we have to admit some
uh point of of ignorance that the model
has some parameters
and so the most uh
glaring uh thing which we don't know
enough about is the strength of
influence of one neuron on another so
the question is how strong are synapses
say in human
cortex
as they operate
and
so again i said so k is how many
pre-synaptic neurons you need
um to cause a post-synaptic neuron
to fire
and certainly the average synapse is
believed to be very weak otherwise
something terrible would happen
but if you've got stronger synapses
then computation that would be very
helpful
and certainly you know
so if you look for them they can be
found but whether they're
dynamic
you need you need them to be a dynamic
if you use them for learning whether
they're dynamic
and what kind of computation they take
part isn't known
so this k this synaptic strength is a
parameter of the model
and
so before i tell you the experimental
results so eventually
so i found two rather different
regimes in which there may be useful
computation to be carried out in this
kind of
framework
and uh so one had uh
uh the first one had weak synapses
many neurons to fire before the person
after neurofires and the second one had
very strong synapses a single neuron
could act on another neuron it's almost
boolean
and
depending on these two assumptions many
things followed
and you get two regimes so in the first
one
the
how it works is that you need very many
neurons to represent the concept r is
large it's huge
but then if it's so huge then you can't
reserve
have each neuron eruptions a different
concept because you don't have enough
neurons
so then it has to be shared
and in the secondary in the second
regime which is kind of more boolean
you can assign a small number like 50
neurons to tiger woods and then you can
have them
disjoint and uh
okay so so the two areas in which it was
worth investigating
okay so these are the simulations so in
this um
so in this uh first regime
so we tried ten to eight neurons some
significant part of a of human brain
eight thousand connections per neuron
these were like long-term connections
this kind of reasonable number
and k was 16
which we thought as largest so you need
16 neurons to
cause a personality neuron to fire or
that's that's the max that's the minimum
you need it of course
they could be weaker
so here we found that you needed vast
number of neurons to represent an item
360 thousand
um but they could be they could be
shared
and in this regime we found that you
could support about three thousand
dollar actions so memorizations whatever
whatever
now this regime is is the one which is
closest to um
to experiments
um in that um
because there are some well-known
experiments where people try to find in
some parts of the brain the ones which
respond to a famous person jennifer
aniston uh bill clinton
and the fact that um by trying a few
neurons
you can find a neuron which
which seems to correspond to this person
you chose in your mind ahead of time
suggests that there are very many of
them
and
another
phenomenon is place cells so if you have
a mouse and you bring it into room then
it's easy enough in the hippocampus to
identify neurons which which respond to
different parts of the space
and again just because it's so easy to
find neurons which correspond to that
corner there must be many of them
so
so this regime with relatively weak
synapses
and many neurons representing
an item
is a
attraction
but the downside is that um this 3200 is
a rather small number
and so certainly we can we as as humans
we have expert knowledge in the
in the
hundreds of thousands
so the other experiment was on the other
regime which had
very strong synapses
um
essentially so boolean strength
and with similar numbers um
so now we could instead of 360 000 we
we only spent 100 neurons on each
concept
and here we could support a quarter
million uh
successive actions
without degrading the earliest ones uh
too much so the
first few things which were memorized
were still there to be
retrieved
okay
okay so
okay so so kind of the summary of what
these experiments
say is something like this we've got
these two regimes weak synapses strong
synapses
and the weak synapses have rather uh
small capacitors
um but one example one advantage is that
these weak synapses support the
algorithms are described
so they're very simple
there are no intermediate neurons
so almost a random collection of neurons
will will achieve this so one can
imagine how evolution would have evolved
these first kind of things
and to get these very large capacitors
which you can achieve by the by the
strong synapses
you have to do
the intermediate nodes the algorithms
get slightly more complicated
complicated so one could imagine that's
a later stage of
of
evolution
so
so quickly these
numbers so
so
an organism in which these numbers have
been measured
is the locust
and one can
explain away a circuit in the locus
quite well using this analysis but i
won't do that
but
what i want to
end on is
is to emphasize one one weakness of what
i've described as a mechanism so the
main problem with what i've described is
that the first operation as i described
hierarchical memorization
is is unstable it's unstable as far as
the number of neurons allocated so i can
assign neurons to
tiger woods but then if i want to assign
more neurons to tiger woods's uncle etc
etc as the net gets deeper the number of
neurons i allocate becomes
unstable
and
in fact we didn't do this for the
simulations we only so that's the one
thing in which we didn't simulate it in
general
and there are various various solutions
to this
um but um so the uh
well the solution which i want to uh
describe
in
the last few slides is the hypothesis
that um
the
the hippocampus
which is about
about one percent of your brain but it
is essential for making uh new memories
his main it's one of his roles is in
fact to allow to help allocate storage
so the simple method of just having
having tiger and woods and looking at
the nodes which are well connected to
both has some instabilities and maybe
you need some extra help by special
purpose mechanism
and i suggest that the hippocampus
does this
so this seems a very natural suggestion
because it's well known that hippocampus
does something it's essential for this
for this kind of activity so the
hippocampus is essential for putting new
memories in your mind like memorizing a
new person um
okay and so it has been identified with
chunking
okay but once i uh identify hierarchical
memorization with allocating uh storage
then this becomes very natural
okay so um
so the hippocampus is a small part of
your brain your neocortex is top left
corner
of course that's the main part this is
not the scale but it's it's a kind of a
feed forward thing with these four
yellow boxes is mainly feet forward
but it's well connected to the rest of
your brain in both directions
and
so it's been a puzzle uh
what what is essential but what is it
what does it do exactly
so um
so what one can show is that it could do
this
stable memory allocation process
so if you look at a feed-forward network
of a small number of layers
of threshold elements
you want to analyze how stable it can
allocate neurons
and if you have the right parameters
then
these are the kind of results you can
get
um so the idea is that on the left hand
side is the density of neurons
which are firing say because you want to
recognize
if tiger and woods are firing but
they're different numbers of neurons and
different depending on what you do
so you put it through a feed-forward
network
and in the end the fraction of neurons
which will fire will be will be very
stable
so
you need to choose the parameters very
carefully to have this effect
but the idea is that in this neuron
allocation process you need some
stabilizing mechanism otherwise
the other explanations are less
satisfactory
and
also the hippocampus has this very
strong association with
with uh
the task of allocating new memory in the
sense that if you lose your hippocampus
then this is exactly what you can what
you cannot do
okay so um so i'll finish
on that so there's your hippocampus the
blue thing
very small part of your brain
which
okay so
the hypothesis so the hypothesis on the
hippocampus
fits in with the uh
with what i've described for
for a way which cortex
may work
um so actually one issue with ma was
that in the end he he tried to connect
his theories of hippocampus and cortex
and i think that's probably when he when
he
he gave up
so what i've described
you have to make some choices in in
doing theoretical neuroscience you have
you need a model of computation
you need a representation you need a
style of algorithms
um
and you have to choose some tasks so you
have to make some choices this is
the the uh
ma plus plus uh
formulation
uh you have to make some choices and
have it fit together and see how it how
it fits uh fits the brain
so thank you
um
yeah yeah yeah yes um
this is but the simulation is tested uh
um
okay so it depends
the simulations tested uh
how well the particular algorithms i had
uh performed on a large scale
on a scale where one couldn't analyze it
anymore you could analyze these things
one shot at a time when the graph was
randomly created in pure but once you
did many operations they
they lost in independence
so they yeah they verify the viability
of these algorithms uh on a scale to
where analysis can go
feedback
well i'm not quite sure what you mean by
the what the model says is that you
somehow you allocate storage for
something first and then there are
thousands of other connections you can
make between the things you've memorized
so that's what you mean by
by redundancy
yes yeah yes so if initially the archive
storage to you memorize tiger woods from
the name
and then if you had some association
well actually then you could also
bring tiger was to mind through a
different line yes
so so you allow massive amount of
redundancy in that sense yes yes that's
the point yeah
um
all the model does is
your science storage is a new concept
and then there's a list of other kinds
of associations you can make and i
listed three i'm interested in
um
maybe maybe you want to add some more
which are more statistical correlational
um
yes there's room for adding more more
more cancer relationships
i don't know whether that answers your
question
okay
can you say something about the query
mechanism in this in this model when i
when i think of retired the first person
that comes to mind is not david beckham
but obviously by overlay other search
terms uh you know british soccer player
then i get back to him i i was thinking
of those connections it's quite
unidirectional
uh if i want to have an association
where i start with the retire and go
back to david do i also simultaneously
need to create
an arrow pointing the other direction
yeah yes so what i do is totally
unidirectional
and from what i said if i say david
beckham you may be reminded that he just
retired or the other way um maybe not so
yeah so in this system you'd you would
deliberately have to do both separately
well
the way i use them they still fall
tolerant because you still have say like
50 100 neurons
and so it's fall tolerance as far as
what
what you um
lose so so um
so i didn't take it too much but for
example in my my semantics
so if i've got r neurons for something
then the semantics in the simulation is
something like um if less than 50
percent of firing then it's not not the
right concept if more than 95 that is
the right concept
and the system is such that the
intermediate thing never happens i guess
so there's room for there's room for
uh fault tolerance at the top um no i do
have i do have fault tolerance
everywhere but i i i see what you're
saying yes
you